my name is bunny fufu and welcome to the
iced coffee hour and i may not be ready
but
i might as well start now great intro
that was one of the best ones that we've
had so far no
no no no no no listen i think you have
the dream job that probably every kid
growing up wants to be you i think it's
actually one of the most sought after
jobs now is being a youtuber so what you
do
you're a part of it
it's what i do but not only that but uh
but your youtube
playing video games you get to play
video games all day long make a
full-time living from it but you're also
making enough money from this to buy a
ton of real estate like some impressive
houses i visited your house i think it
was win almost two years ago i think so
around then yeah it's like 5 000 square
feet it's like four it's he's got a four
story thousands yes they have four-story
house it's a big one yeah i guess does
the roof count as a for as a story yes
oh yeah yeah it does it does all right
three and a half we'll go with that
because you got every room decked out
like i kid you not i walked in and you
would imagine like a college dorm room i
always get made fun of for the amount of
computers i have in my home yeah how
many computers do you have too many too
many is it over 10 it is over 10. yeah
oh my god one room has like 10 computers
seriously you go down to the basement
and there's like a row of 20 computers
and you go down there and there's like
people down there
like 24 7. you walk downstairs there's
like 10 dudes just with their their
headphones on wait and that's currently
looking away and that's here in las
vegas yes yeah you got to come over i
would love to game game with all of us
yeah
i used to game all the time that is so
cool i would love to yeah and i was
actually blown away too you had a chef a
private chef yeah yep yep yep i think
[Music]
a lot of people think it's very bougie
and waste money but i kind of just view
it as i cook extremely slow i eat
extremely slow so as much time as i can
save as possible when it comes to
someone doing something for me i like to
spend money there to earn some time back
it's also probably healthier it is yeah
yeah i've noticed uh
before in the early days of starting
this whole business it was just
costco the most unhealthy foods frozen
foods 24 7. you just feel like garbage
all the time yeah so tell us about this
business because i think a lot of people
look at like the youtube gaming space
you're like oh you just play video games
all day long that's all you're doing but
see i i don't think people really
understand like how much of a serious
business this is and like how many
people you have working for you and just
like just everything behind it you've
really built your own like video game
kind of empire here i think we should
also introduce our guests do them a
little bit of justice uh bunny fufu
youtuber business owner been in the
youtube game for how long
uh probably full time like three to four
years now three to four years and
started out playing video games and uh
got really competitive so yeah backtrack
uh the game we're talking about is
league of legends i played that
all throughout my high school my friend
showed it to me in the beginning of my
high school
and
played that got pretty good near my
junior senior year and then when i was a
senior in high school
i would uh i got i was pretty high up on
the leaderboards so a professional team
reached out to me and said hey we want
you to play for our team try out what
not and so um
the tryout went extremely well
there were a bunch of people trying out
at the time and uh
i guess i knocked it out of the park
because after two games they were like
all right i guess you're the one come up
to la this weekend and play with us and
then uh did that and so that went well
as well and then for my whole senior
year i went from
going to school during the week and then
going up to la on the weekends and
competing and then repeat
until the end of my high school career
and then i uh
moved into gaming house after gaming
house after high school
and then should i just keep going wait
wait wait how do you go you how did you
get some good gaming house and yeah do
you guys how did you get so good in
three years because i played dota for
like four and i did not get that good
all right how many hours would you say
did it take you to actually become
literally lots of hours i think everyone
who ends up going pro obviously it
starts out as passion they just sink
everything into it like if you are
trying to balance something else with
balancing this it's just not gonna
happen do you what about high school
like how long were you playing in high
school did your grades suffer did your
parents ever be like you gotta you
listen you gotta get a job one day you
gotta go to college yes school was
definitely not my my gig no no no no i
think that's a big motivation i have to
work so hard on what i do is because
it's like
if this doesn't work go to school okay
that's not even an option so this has to
work yeah
you just really don't want to go back to
school yeah that's what you said it's a
good motivator honestly right but did
you have a good relationship with your
parents where they at least understood
what you were doing or were they like as
long as you just like see yeah uh
the best
convincer can you guys guess what it is
the best thing to do money
yeah are you making are you making money
yep once the money came in it was
get down it's dinner time after money
okay bring dinner up i'll see you in 30
minutes
well how much how much money is it like
we're talking like a hundred bucks you
were talking you were like this is when
you were 18. uh like high school i did
something that's actually um frowned
upon in the game i would help you i
would get banned for this saying this
but i think it was so long ago that
doesn't matter yeah and uh i plan on
being extremely open this podcast so i
could shoot myself in the foot but i'm
trying to be more spontaneous so i'm
just going to lay it all out there and
i'm sure it'll be
entertaining because that's probably
what you want to hear i want to we want
to hear the entertaining stuff we can
put a mid-roll ad right here
[Laughter]
you think i'm joking but
i don't know if then we'll see so
financial is up for you
uh what was the original question before
we got into how entertaining this was
going to be money money from starting
out
i would actually rank people up in the
game
oh
no way yeah it's against the terms you
could carry people i i would go on their
account and rank them up and they would
pay me and that which is totally legal
right please don't ban me explain this
it was so long ago i don't do this
anymore explain this i so i'm not so you
you suck at the game right yeah you play
you play with a bunch of friends yeah
you want to look like you're good
you would give me a hundred dollars i
would take you from this rank to this
rank and now you look good in front of
your friends you would play with he
would play with you in competitive games
i i would log into your account yeah oh
you played four
which is why it's illegal which is why
it was very long time ago please don't
ban me from the game i play okay
you would play for repeat wait wait so
this is how you were making money
originally originally the very first
money i started making how much were
they paying yeah well yeah and how do
you how do they find you they just reach
out to you or how do you um
my mother's listed on some like random
form and then it's honestly it was a lot
of word of mouth and then it got to the
point where there were so many people
asking me to do it i had a bunch of
other good friends that were good at the
game and i would give them jobs and take
50 of what they get give them 50
everyone's happy so now what i was like
indirectly starting a business from very
early on that turned out to be pretty
lucrative and fun and then i stopped i
don't like i said i haven't done it for
a long time please don't ban me from the
game i like you guys just how much how
much were you making um back then it was
like maybe a couple grand a month no
that's great yeah holy crap this is
pretty cool couple grand a month you got
to think too let's say three three a
month i'm just sitting like yeah i think
it was
yeah that's a hundred bucks a day
for being 18 years old playing video
games and then to free up more of my
time i would pay my classmates money to
do my homework so i could save time
there
and
you're outsourcing more people yeah
wow and and for the fact that i had no
idea what to do on my homework and i
would have failed anyways so you know
what i've never told anybody this i did
that in high school too you paid people
you just changed yeah then i paid i paid
someone to do my homework my size how
much have you had uh i think it was like
200 bucks it was it was a lot now this
is when i was working at the uh at the
aquarium spot
and uh there's this guy victor who was
really really really good at i think it
was chemistry
and
there was some sort of final or
something where i think i would have to
have retook the class over summer oh so
and so for me it was like i wanted to
work so it's worth it for me to pay the
200 bucks and you know what the funny
thing is he got a higher grade from me
than he did on his own test because i
think he took his first and then took
mine right after and this is we were
doing like the online stuff so like you
just basically had to log in your stuff
online type in the answers that's so
funny see my teacher's name i wasn't
going to get a good grade and the person
who's helping me cheat would
a student so i actually purposely told
him not to give me a good grade i would
show up and be like hey give me a b
today and then he would help me out wow
yeah that's smart that's very smart
that's impressive you can't throw the
teachers off guardians yeah
yeah you can't go from like an f student
to like an a-plus because then it's like
obvious you're cheating
that's i don't want to endorse any of
this obviously but uh
okay so you're making good money in high
school and then you decide what not to
go to college
um so and then uh after i noticed how i
had a real shot of like becoming a
professional at it obviously doing that
kind of stuff was frowned upon and
you'll get um it's honestly it doesn't
help you get that much good at the game
because or that good at the game because
you're playing versus really bad people
you're not going to get you're not going
to improve doing that so i basically
stopped doing that so my income went
down to zero because i went to focusing
on practicing 24 7 to possibly get on
one of those
pro teams and then my dad was like all
right money stopped what happened what's
going on here i'm like dad trust me like
it's this this is a good opportunity and
he's like nope this is not good go
outside and then it went back to doing
that again
and then uh
my mom's super supportive about it uh
whether it was money or not really and
then uh
after practicing getting good at the
game i got that shot to try out and then
that's where i was talking about got the
tryout nailed that and started going up
to
the weekends and competing there and
then money started coming back in from
that source which was
winning tournaments and stuff uh it's
kind of like the nfl but for nerds it's
called the lcs league legends
championship series i don't know if you
guys know much about it now
but um basically the game creator
started its own league where there's
like uh a franchise where it's it's like
the nfl you know there's 32 teams they
compete and they have his regular season
playoffs and then they move on and
whatnot
uh same same concept so there's 10 teams
and then i found my way onto one of
those teams to compete in there and it's
a pretty legitimate like
it's
way more diligent now than it was back
then but even back then i was still
pretty legit and the owner of the team
had a sit-down conversation with my
parents and was like listen your son's
really good like
trust me he's has potential of making
this work into a career and would show
all the other people that have succeeded
in that category and then she was like
okay we'll give it a shot and then
yeah
and and once you joined this team how
were you receiving income was it just by
by winning tournaments and playing with
this team against the other nine teams
or was it through like a salary from the
franchise so riot the owner of the game
created this whole concept because they
knew video games were very
you show up to a tournament you can only
make money if you win and that's
obviously a not a sustainable way to
live because if you suck for
six months you're going bankrupt and you
have to not play the game anymore so the
whole reason behind this whole franchise
thing was to because um was because they
want to make it more sustainable so
it was all salary based from teams and
it was like you compete for this team
you get a salary i think my salary first
starting out was like
um
it kind of just exponentially went up
and it started out as like a thousand
dollars
but first i want to thank our sponsor
ladder really quick i want to talk about
the things that fundamentally change the
way that we live these things are called
disruptors disruptors are things such as
youtube smartphones and even internet
banking jack another disruptor is
actually our sponsor today ladder ladder
basically took the life insurance
industry flipped it upside down and
shook out all the inefficiencies before
ladder you actually have to drive across
town fill out a ton of paperwork and
then you still had to wait six to eight
weeks to find out if you were approved
not to mention the countless amounts of
phone calls that you would get from
other agents trying to bundle your life
insurance with car insurance but now we
live in a new era an era where i can buy
dogecoin at the click of a button an era
where i can drink milk straight from the
carton wait a second i didn't know about
that one alex but most importantly an
era where you can get approved all
online for term life insurance for 3
million or less in coverage and if
you're between the ages of 20 and 60 and
you want term life insurance to protect
you and your family choose ladder go to
ladderlife.com
iced coffee today to see if you are
instantly approved that's ladderlife.com
iced coffee you mean
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
iced coffee ladderlife.com iced coffee
thank you so much ladder for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast
then a month yeah a month
okay so that's not much i mean so you do
you have another source of income coming
in back then or is it just like th this
was this was like a lot of the time okay
but um
i think this was for one of the amateur
teams i was on
because i i went from being at the
highest level to amateur team to highest
level amateur team like multiple times
um on the professional team it was 4k a
month when i was on the
team that was in the franchise this is
probably so confusing i'm doing a whole
job explaining yeah yeah i'm following
i'm following yeah yeah okay
amateur a thousand professional four
yeah they have like major league and
minor league basically where you can
revolve between the two okay and then um
nowadays it's way different we can fast
forward as much as you guys want how
many years ahead you guys want to travel
i want your help yeah so so when you
were making a thousand dollars a month
you were still making this commute here
from las vegas all the way over there um
this was after my high school all my
friends were like we're gonna go to
college we're gonna go to college i'm
like oh
i think i'm gonna go and live with a
bunch of dudes and play video games and
they were like
that makes no sense good luck you know
because a lot of the people in my high
school were just had college ready to go
right it kind of sucks how it's like the
normal thing now i think i know not all
my friends went to college yeah they
they thought it was crazy for not going
like nuts and you know what for me the
part that i hated the most was the
parents the parents were like oh where
are you going oh you're not going what
are you are you planning on going
next year
i was like no i'm gonna get my real
estate license oh
okay like really just like they just
talked down to you it's dude i hate it i
couldn't stand it i'm like i'm gonna
show you
[Music]
oh yeah so so you were living with this
at this gaming house were they charging
you rent because you're only making a
thousand dollars a month yeah this was
after high school imagine they charge it
down
950
this was after high school i moved up to
la and uh
this is in the early stages of things
things are way different now sure you
would be surprised how professional
things are now but back then it was
two people living in a king-size bed it
was
the coach living in the closet it was me
in the corner of the room on a twin bed
so like super ghetto at the time they're
not making me payment for that i'm sure
you're probably curious about that um
but it was basically just the team
working their booty off to get as good
as possible to see where this uh
industry goes you know
what team was that
um it was team curse at the time they're
team liquid now i mean i'm sure they
probably don't like me saying there were
four people living in the same room
i've heard of liquid yeah but i mean the
thing is you got to do what you got to
do i don't think there's
anything honorable yeah i think it's a
badge of honor the fact that like you're
willing to do anything it takes like
that's just what it's uh required you
have to do that i know there's a funny
story where
the owner of the team was like hey bunny
like we love having you here but like
careful going outside like there's a
actually the hoa limits you of how many
people can live in a current building so
i thought that was so my god steve i'm
sorry if this is bad i shouldn't say
this but i think i think it's funny all
right we're going to be very open on
this podcast i'm not going to die from
saying a lot of things i'm saying what's
that going to happen uh what about the
first tournament that you did you ever
win a tournament like a big tournament
um it's honestly like uh think of it
like you know how i said the nfl yeah
these 10 teams they're in a regular
season and then there's a playoffs
and then once you win playoffs you go to
worlds and compete against everyone in
the world
so for those who know about league of
legends you probably know exactly what
i'm talking about not knowing anything
it's probably extremely confusing i'm
sorry
now what's the farthest you ever got um
unfortunately i never went to worlds but
i did compete in uh
there's like live stages and all that
stuff so it's uh
hard to explain it's hard to answer that
question i guess have you ever gotten a
tournament winning
um we were first place in the regular
season for a while
in playoffs um top four i believe
it's pretty it's pretty competitive hard
stuff sounds like it yeah so what
happened after that then
you're making 4k i'm guessing you got to
be like 19 at that time 20. uh something
around that yeah okay so and then after
that season ended um
it was a pretty
not established organization and then
the established organizations just try
to grab all the best players they can
so um
i don't know if you guys have heard of
cloud9
they snagged me
tsm team solomid they snagged one of our
other players
um another established team grabbed one
of the players so our our team was
pretty good but since it wasn't that uh
stable of an organization all the
players just ended up getting
boom disbanded and then so i went to
cloud9 and then my salary went up to 8
000 a month playing for them and i was
actually a substitute at the time under
someone who um
was really experienced at the game and i
kind of went under his wing to learn
about the game and learn about how i can
improve as a player and that was pretty
cool
and then what
and the story goes on once i need to
drink some water here
oh wow that's a really nice mug
that is that's is that bankroll coffee
that's crazy wow where you could get
your coffee now for sale at
bankrollcoffee.com it's the most
cost-effective coffee delivered straight
to your door online
exactly locally growth roasted as let's
say roasted and ethically sourced
bankroll that's what i'm drinking right
now i like that
so eight thousand dollars a month while
you were like 21. back to the boring
story no i'm just kidding i'm going to
try to make this as entertaining as
possible and we'll get to the juice
eight grand a month is great yeah and by
playing video games like i mean i'm
guessing you're probably putting in like
12 14 hours of work every day it's a lot
yeah yeah just practicing so being on
that team um
it was super good i learned a lot being
a starter or a substitute whatever it
was at the time the salary was the same
all the way through
and then fast forward about a year
i noticed uh
i got basically replaced at the time to
be as blunt as possible and i was like
here we go again it was a top team so
essentially if you get kicked from a top
team you have a lot of opportunities to
join a lower tier team may have the same
salary but
it is a stressful life because if you
play bad for like two weeks or three
weeks you're going to get replaced and
someone else is going to take your spot
so obviously that's not really
when you say playing bad you mean you're
just like losing yeah like you suck at
the game
why would you play better like what what
would cause you to suck that game have
you ever played a video game no but if
you're playing good right why would you
suddenly play bad
uh because you're okay let's say you are
a baseball dude so you're a great chess
player i'm a great chess player yeah
you're gonna beat me sometimes if you
beat me more often than not i'm getting
from here down to here right so it's
obvious basically it's like you ever
heard of a slump
that's like a thing people go through
where you just go through a bad spell
like just okay you're swinging and
missing yeah badge every batting yard is
low for two months you're probably going
on a lower two teams so i noticed being
on the top team i had the opportunity to
join five other teams at the time
and i was like do i really want to keep
living this life of
working or playing for 12 14 hours a day
feeling guilty to go out with my
girlfriend at the time because i should
be practicing and it's like that level
of guilt is just not something i want to
live with so instead of
joining another one of those five teams
and just being stuck in that race of
being in that league that's um very high
demanding
um content creation was an option
because one of the players on my team
was actually extremely popular he would
stream on twitch and he would get like
20 000 viewers every stream what's his
name uh sneaky
sneaky yeah everyone has such cool names
mine is just graham and yours is jack
you've never had a gamer name yeah why
not like bunny fufu man
that's cool bunny fufu man
that's our new adaptation
but first i want to thank helix sleep
for sponsoring this episode so i
recently received my helix and i gotta
say it is 1 000 times better than
whatever mattress gram had me use before
i actually got some great sleep for the
first time in a while and i woke up
refreshed and ready to take on my day
and watch 10 meet kevin videos choosing
the right helix mattress for me was
super quick and easy helix sleep has a
quiz that matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you with helix sleep you're
getting a mattress that fits the way
that you sleep not anyone else and just
on a personal level sleep has actually
always been something that i've
struggled with and i've found it is one
of the biggest determinants of how
productive you are in a day and how
happy you are in a day seriously though
everyone is unique and we all sleep
differently and helix has mattresses for
almost everything that you can imagine
they have mattresses that are soft
medium and firm and they even have
mattresses that are made for cooling you
down if you sleep a little hot which i
do they even have mattresses made for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and even helix plus for plus-sized
sleepers did someone say plus size just
go to
helixsleep.comcoffee and take the
two-minute sleep goods they'll match you
to a customized mattress that'll give
you the best sleep of your life there's
a 10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for a hundred nights risk free and
they will even come and pick it up from
you if you don't love it but i know you
will helix is offering up to 200 off and
two free pillows for our listeners when
you use the link helix sleep dot com
slash coffee that's helix sleep.com
coffee thank you so much helix for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
we gotta have cool names all right so
we're getting to the juice soon um
he basically took me under his wing and
helped me grow as a influencer
essentially so
and i knew uh streaming was still really
demanding and then my friend at the time
who did youtube for the game i play
he told me how much it he made and it
was
six digits a month and i was like okay
well that's my new job
from youtube yes and that's adsense what
was sponsorships
uh that was just ad revenue at the time
actually no yep can we ask you that no
how many views was he pulling a month a
lot he was getting about a million a
video
wow yeah so once he told me that i'm
like all right well the fact that you
can play one game upload that to however
many people
instead of streaming and being
entertaining for 10 hours straight
the one game sounds much more nice and
so i knew from the get-go yeah
i would funnel everyone i had on stream
into my youtube channel to promote that
because i knew that's something i wanted
to do
so you're streaming on twitch at this
time how many people were watching you
on twitch
um only about like maybe i say only that
sounds kind of bm but
compared to the more successful people
on the platform it's not a crazy amount
anywhere from like maybe 500 to 2 000
okay yeah
got it so you're taking those people to
youtube what year was this it must been
17 2017 i got a timeline i know i know
we need like a powerpoint presentation
maybe like six years ago now
we're getting closer to the present all
right
and whenever he would funnel me uh you
can host on stream so yeah my viewers
let's say i'm streaming with 50 000
people i give them all to you maybe 20
000 stay and watch your stuff and then
they like you they don't and i'd be like
hey guys i have a pretty cool youtube
channel if you want to check out that
every time he would show me viewers
right
that eventually grew into something so
sneaky hosted you a lot yeah exactly
and that's something where i knew i was
like let me take this opportunity
because sneaky is amazing and uh helping
me out instead of rejoining another team
rejoining the stressful
you can get benched at any moment of
time if you have a slump for two weeks
you know what i mean it's very not fun
got it so you're building up this
youtube channel yeah what were you
posting back then were you just taking
your twitch streams and then repackaging
them yeah basically on stream i would
play a game of league of legends and
then i would cut out that game editor
slap on some memes during the video and
post that and then that would be my
content how often were you posting it's
daily daily this was back when youtube
really promoted daily content yeah yeah
they were huge on that a while ago yeah
i remember this was uh it was 2017 where
daily content was like the thing to do
it was crazy and i remember
uh it was ricky gutierrez who was
trading stocks and one of the reasons
why his channel did so well in the
beginning was because he posted every
single day brand new youtube promoted
that so hard it was so it was pretty
stressful as a creator too where trying
to one up yourself daily that's like
unheard of yeah and then this i love
talking about old youtube trends uh it
was uh mid 2017 they started pushing
live videos like crazy they were trying
to compete with twitch and i remember
that
i was thinking to myself i can't post
videos anymore because they would just
promote the live streams and so i was
like oh man am i going to have to do
live streams now like for the algorithm
it only lasted a few months youtube's
making a really big push on that now by
the way we're jumping to the present
also but they just signed a few giant
twitch creators to go on stream on
youtube which is really cool wow
all right giant creators so anyway so
you're posting daily on youtube uh the
one this is the main channel the bunny
fufu channel yep and now i'm really
sorry this has turned into like a
biography i really want to get in some
like juice soon but once we catch up the
present i promise you i got some stuff
in my mind that graham is probably not
going to put on his podcast but we'll
see how it goes let's see
i'm inclined to keep a lot of this on
there and let's just get your handshake
i'm way i'm going to get my way outside
my comfort zone
and then you know let's try worst case
we cut it out but i'm i'm inclined to
keep most of it on there all right
we're getting outside our comfort zone
here all right um but to catch you up
for the present sneaky helped me out um
and then i had to leave the team house
at the time because obviously i wasn't
on team anymore and i moved into la rand
oh my gosh lauren is that why you left
too it's just too expensive uh not the
rent just taxes yeah yeah yeah but
essentially uh i knew i did i like the
l.a rent as a landlord
allie rent's too low
[Laughter]
i knew i didn't want to pay that too low
la rent at the time
and so only rent needs to be higher oh
jeez graham's trying to raise your hand
no i'm kidding i'm kidding but seriously
so um i was my girlfriend at the time
and i was like listen i'm gonna move
back to san diego into my dad's house to
save money and i want to invite people
to help me with my youtube channel back
there and she was like no i don't really
want to do that we kind of split went
our separate ways from then on
and on yeah you guys broke up yeah we
broke up because
were you guys living together at the
time yeah yeah how long have you guys
been dating
maybe
a year year and a half well living
together that's the thing you can't just
say like i'm going to move back in with
my dad and have a whole bunch of guys
live with me
i would say most women
would be like well wouldn't yeah because
then you're kind of kicking around
you're kind of regressing in the
relationship yeah
yeah i see that i see your point of view
no no listen i'm trying to i'm trying to
like be on your side
he chose he chose work right i mean
that's totally fine yeah
yeah because
a couple thousand dollars or free rent
at my dad's house it's the financial
decision that you should make
obviously a good decision yeah
and then so i did that for about two
years imagine you're like i miss her
every day
every day
that's why i came on the podcast please
just call me back
please
i give it all random questions any
guests ever cried on the podcast no oh
boy all right well
if you want to be the
first feel free to let us know on the
podcast graham let's get emotional with
you later okay
i'm not gonna hold back this is the
handshake we made to make sure graham
cries and now i can keep that in the
video for you guys all right listen i'm
i'm open to i'm about
i honestly have some questions that i'm
gonna ask myself you guys all right that
macy might kill me for sure macy
what is that girlfriend yeah yeah yeah
yeah she might kill you if i asked some
of the questions i met oh jeez let's see
okay
i'm in the handshake a lot of this is
staying in the video let's see all right
so to catch up to the present um
worked on my dad's house for two years
saves enough to move to las vegas i mean
you know why moving to las vegas is
great i'm sure all your viewers do stay
income tax cheaper yadda yadda more room
boom now
been doing this for three years in las
vegas have been expanding my real estate
portfolio here
and we're finally to the present and we
can now get into some juice
how many how many properties
wait how many properties do you own
no more what do you mean we're almost
done no here's the thing man you can't
just go from that until then like you
own like five properties you own five
properties no how many properties you
have i have four currently and i have
two more in the works
in the works like the under contract or
what um
yeah so
american west homes you guys know how it
works basically like you can like
customize your home and they build
around it'll take like nine months and
you can kind of pick and choose what you
want
two of those in the works right now got
it here's the part that i wanted to talk
briefly about is that you have like an
entire content house basically where
you're posting content but you also have
people that live with you that also post
content yeah and you basically are are
you a manager of them and you get like a
cut it's like house manager half they
help me with content it's like basically
uh i have a few homes dedicated to this
whole project where it's either you're
helping me with what i'm doing whether
it's a manager or a youtube manager or
people that play with me to help me to
look as good as possible it's a mixture
of a bunch of things
and or uh they're a content creator and
they move in and
i take a percentage of what they make by
helping promote them it's a whole
many different avenues you go down that
are
do you rent out the other houses to con
content creators as well or is this just
your main house um so i have three right
now dedicated to everyone who's helping
me and i'm helping them and then
one
is fully i don't touch rental property
passive income which
back when i first realized you moved to
my dad's house it's nice i can refer to
my timeline now because people are kind
of caught up to speed yeah that's when i
originally started watching you oh cool
yeah yeah back with about 150k
subscribers the whole
um
uh real estate passive income i i really
think
once
you
stop having to trade your time for money
you can unlock a new level of yourself
where
you don't like feel guilty for doing
what you're doing it helps with
happiness a lot in my opinion sure
because let's say you go to disneyland
if
you work for your money
it's like you're just trading your time
for your money and you're always worried
like is this was it worth it was this
experience nice but
if you have passive income that you
literally don't have to work for you can
enjoy experiences without having to
worry i traded two hours for this or i
traded five hours for this or ten hours
you know what i mean yeah that's pretty
cool so you're talking about this with
your rental property yeah got it but
then what about the business the
business that's the juicy part the
business that's the juicy part um if i
dance around any areas of the business
it's
not because i am the most open person
whether it's
personal life or business or money or
whatever but if i do dance around
anything it's most likely to um
respect the people who work for marie
and
their
side of things so
you would be open to saying just your
own income without
maybe you guys
[Laughter]
that's what we've been leading up to
this entire time
um
we need a bit of click bait here that's
all expenses or non-expenses what do you
guys what are you looking for gross and
then net
and then network
and then we want to see what's in your
bank account yeah all your credit cards
and your investments account we want to
know where you're investing too and what
what was your social security yeah
social security number oh we'll get to
all that um it's anywhere between like
maybe 70k and 100k a month uh
growth yeah right after expenses
expenses are anywhere from about
35 to 45.
and those expenses are so unheard of
yeah that's really high but is it
expenses it's got to be equipment it's
got to be equipment i always want to
pull up my spreadsheet yeah everything i
spent because every month i'll sit down
with my cpa and look at every expense i
have
maybe i should bring you into lesnar
that's too high yeah you can really take
a look what
housing is probably six of that
uh
probably you're paying out a lot more
with electricity depending on a lot of
people hang out a lot of people there's
editors there's the list goes on and on
i will gladly
go through my monthly expenses with you
and then maybe after the video you can
be like guys i approve you know what i
have you know what this is horrible he
is an idiot i have a feeling it's not
frivolous
i really i mean yeah he's going through
every expense of this honestly honestly
early on
i i was i was stupid and i learned a lot
from where i was overspending where i
was under uh underspending but i feel
like i've been doing it for so long i
would be a complete idiot if i was still
doing it poorly yeah at this point in
time i don't think you are
yeah just knowing you what do you know
about the only the only thing the only
thing that uh i've seen you going out to
clubs now oh my gosh i've seen like i
said we're gonna be getting some juice
yeah we're talking a lot about money
right now yeah but there's going to be
some a lot of personal well you go for
it you know what you've been you've been
this entire time you've been wanting to
you you've been hinting at it what's the
juice the entire spill the tea you want
to know the juice okay fine every minute
you're like we're gonna get to the juice
so boring autobiography i listen i like
the boy being a gamer while i was i like
that i like that how old are you i'm 27.
i just recently turned 25. okay 25. yep
so we're like the same age heck you nice
let's go to the clubs let's do it yeah
i'd love to
25 is too old for the class is it really
no no but um
growing up the whole now that you guys
know my backstory this is actually
really nice that we can it's not like
out of the blue uh putting 12 14 hour
days in every single day including
weekends
i'm basically 19 years old right now
i'm basically
a fetus coming out of the womb currently
so
there's still so much that i'm now
learning in the personal side of things
yeah that's not
play 12 hours a day watch video invest
yeah invest your money live like a robot
you know what i mean it's very got it
yeah i could see that because you're
basically fermenting yeah
you went in hibernation basically
yeah yeah yeah
well i think 25 is still young i mean
and i think just like recently just now
recently i've noticed um
i actually broke up with my ex about
maybe like a year ago i don't really
know the exact timeline
uh because
things were going well the relationship
was it was going well and whatnot but
you wanted to spread your wings spread
my wings
start new business adventures that don't
really promote a healthy relationship
yeah and basically wait wait wait what
do you mean
you guys are starting to find some juice
going on here
oh this is the juice i think i know what
it is
i'm
this guy's trying to dive into it right
now you broke up with your girlfriend
even though the relationship was going
well yes i think that's a personal
growth thing honestly i because i think
once you once you take that leap of
faith you're all in on everything you
know that's actually i like messing with
you at the time you're like hey man if
you ever need anything like reach out i
thought that was super awesome we didn't
have like a crazy
friendship relationship at the time but
you were like hey man if you ever need
anything like i'm in vegas i got you you
know i thought that was super cool what
what did i respond to with that really
we'll bust it out right now we can pull
up some dm's get some screenshots
boom it's up right now graham's a super
wholesome guy believe it or not
i try to be throwing out a hand when
there's no value for him to gain you
know what i mean i try to be i i always
act like the algorithm is watching
that's my moral compass it's like what's
what's the algorithm going to do
well i'm glad i did that but you know i
honestly i think uh
probably you know i don't know the
intricate details of your relationship i
think it's probably the right choice
yeah i think uh i think we're about to
have a dinner some weekend and i was
like listen graham things aren't going
so hard now you're man i remember yeah
and then we canceled our dinner because
yeah the double date was now it was
about to be meet third wheeling right
yeah
are you with a new girl currently uh
it's complicated
that i'm assuming you probably won't
that's the chance no i am completely
open
is that the girl that you were just
talking to yeah why is it complicated
okay oh boy let me drink it i think i
think i'm gonna i don't want to say it i
want you to say it okay
i want to guess like i said i am i am
very open
let me readjust my position you've
changed i i listen
yeah because when i when i met you two i
think it was like two years ago give or
take about two years ago i remember you
just being like so
into the business oh gaming
and it was just like your entire life
was gaming and we met at a sushi place
and you're like right back to gaming and
you gave us like these really cool
hoodies so i have this back then we can
refer to the timeline it was like
a random thing i had in la i was at my
dad's house i was watching graham at the
time 200k subscribers i'm like hey
graham i'm in la you want to get dinner
instantly says yes i'm like i remember
it that was easy this was this was big
for me because this is like just as my
youtube channel was taking off and i
think you were trying to message me get
to know people that were also doing
something similar yeah
yeah you messaged me i was like whoa
this is crazy and you're like you tell
you tell the story i'll never forget
this um basically
uh i was on a business trip that
everything was paid for so i was like
graham pick the nicest place in l.a
we're going right now he's like
are you sure they're going to pay this
amount of money if we go to dinner i'm
like yeah let's do it and then that's
where we first met in person
i was i by the way i was like are you
sure are you sure i feel bad even during
the dinner i'm like
you see that steak that's the one i'm
getting you're like why are you doing
that i'm like waku i'm like graham it's
funny it was a one wagoo at mastros that
was like two hundred dollars no like a
little tiny bit and i think we got a few
ounces of it like enough where everybody
got a bite have you ever heard of
hearthstone
it's a popular video game they make oh
hearthstone yeah of course dude i played
that they paid for that wagyu steak no
way
blizzard yeah yeah oh my gosh yeah yeah
we got oh i remember then we got the
lobster mac and cheese we went a little
crazy we went nuts it was it was like
about six hundred dollars yeah and i
think didn't didn't we get uh did we get
something to drink there because usually
i never drink but this would have been
one of the few times where i would have
gotten drinking i'm pretty sure we
didn't know i i didn't drink much got it
okay now back then now i'm on a
five-week bender going strong now the
juice is coming out listen graham okay
let's get into what's gonna happen okay
graham you're gonna absolutely love my
old self all right you're gonna love it
i don't worry i still have a part of me
inside you i'd still like to be a
financial you're inside graham
now you're gonna start liking the new
side yeah all right
coming inside me yeah dude all right
let's see
inside you now let's go i've been around
the block let's let's hear it let's hear
it
oh boy okay so where do we begin i'm
talking about okay we can get into a lot
of a lot of stuff right now so
either i can poke at some things or you
guys don't ask a question i like open as
you want i like the fact that you said
you feel like you're 19 emotionally yeah
not like maturity wise because you're
clearly more mature than that i think
but you said emotionally 19. so i don't
i think socially socially 19 because you
haven't had those college experiences
yeah so you've missed out on all of that
but now but here's the problem you're
going into that now with money in a
business
you got a lot more to lose i think some
19 year olds having money can help
accelerate your growth
very fast or it could or it's here's the
thing having money is like driving a
lambo at 16. like yeah you could go
faster but like gosh you could you go
out of control so fast yeah yeah yeah so
in two months i could be bankrupt and
asking this i don't think you're
listening i don't think you're going to
be bankrupt but uh anyway let's share it
let's see if it could happen you know
okay so you're the voice of reading you
broke up with this girl that it was
going perfectly fine with yeah and then
you decided to focus on your business
and everything or personally i broke up
because um
i
still to this day have not had like a
one-night stand
and i feel like
uh now we can get into like a bucket
list thing of random things that i feel
like i need to do to experience life at
its fullest but i'd say that probably
the biggest reason was to start a
business where
i promote
um females to grow on social media i
knew it i knew it i literally i knew it
it's pretty awesome
so you do only fans production uh that's
one way to put it yet yeah
well you know what i mean it was so
funny i'm not going to mention names but
there's somebody else who has the exact
same story as you yeah really literally
the exact are you oh you know what i'm
talking about yeah i know you're talking
yeah which is crazy because you guys are
both about the same age
maybe i don't know what what field is or
am i poking at me too much
i'm not going to reveal anything
after this okay but uh literally the
exact same perfectly perfectly like
normal you know great relationship great
guy uh yeah great relationship great
everything stand up guy honestly uh got
into that business too just on the side
yeah it's disgusting pools wait what's
disgusting man tread lightly
it's uh it's definitely lucrative but
yeah something that i like even more
than the money
is doing youtube
um
before it was kind of like same thing
different day and it came into a rut of
like i i'm genuinely just not
challenging myself yeah whether it's
business whether it's personal
and like the money was great and
obviously i watched your videos and i
know if i buy a bunch of real estate and
live off passive income that's
can you cuss on here
preferably not effing amazing okay sure
if you do alex would leap it out gotcha
you could let you could let one slip but
uh yeah
so uh i knew that
um
being as lucky as i am to be in a
situation to work my absolute booty off
and take advantage of the situation
because high views are not going to be
there forever you know
like i think even now they're definitely
not at what they once were
but it's nice that i can finally
feel
it was actually the first rental
passive income
uh amount of money i had come into my
bank was like wow
i didn't work for that like i think that
was one thing recently that has changed
my outlook on
um
just how i view life now okay
and sorry what was the question i'm
starting to ramble a bit the juice
what's going on
um okay so um
so you wanted to try something new to
reinvigorate like your excitement right
yeah so um
i knew now be the time to start this
only fans business and now would be the
only time to
take advantage of the situation while
you're no yeah did you did you try to
keep the relationship with your
girlfriend or was it like i know it's
not going to work i want to do all these
things let's end it now
it was pretty much i knew it wasn't
going to work she wouldn't have
supported that yeah and like we talked
about this we were completely opening
the whole situation and kind of just
understood that
uh she wanted to get more serious more
sooner than i wanted to and um i was not
ready to get any serious any time soon
so kind of paths go in different ways is
what it is we it was funny on our
breakup it was like she called her
parents and was like hey um
yeah like we broke up and like i i knew
them really well and everything was
great and they were like oh my gosh i'm
sorry to hear this like when should i
come out and get you she was like oh
maybe like two or three weeks doesn't
really matter and it's like after a
breakup that's not like a thing you know
you don't just it's very amicable and
yeah yeah yeah
so um i thought that was pretty funny
um fast forward a bit started this
business and then uh
like i said i've learned probably more
in the past like four or five months of
my life doing this project than i have
in the past three to four years doing
the same thing different day what have
you learned
oh boy i'm still learning so i could be
wrong what exactly are you doing
yeah what are you doing and what do you
like do you have like a warehouse or
where you like have sets and stuff
uh that's the plan it's all
funneling money into growing this whole
thing whether it's like new sets for
shoots or
going on trips to make better videos or
whatnot
but essentially it's make gaming videos
with
females that help
i honestly think
there's so many hot girls on the
internet these days where
you now need a reason to subscribe to
someone and give them money to support
them like you can find a hot girl
anywhere now you know you go on
instagram
boobs everywhere but if you can see
someone's personality through long-form
content whether it's a podcast or a
youtube video or whatnot you'll fall in
love with that person and then want to
see more of that first
[Music]
more of their personalities
all right listen it's always good it's a
business it's a business i'm i'm all for
business it's a free enterprise i'm all
for sure listen as long as as long as
everyone's happy i'm all for it but i
don't even know if i'm cutting any of
this out of the video or not this is
great now i love that oh boy okay so are
you making more money doing that than
you are from youtube or um it's still
it's still pretty new like i said i'm
not even looking only towards the money
side of things i'm actually risking a
lot of the money that i'm
making currently by doing such
provocative content
and i'm sure it's not algorithm friendly
but right i'm very big on uh i i like
where this is going and i feel like i'm
learning a lot i don't think i'm in a
situation where i have
fu money and i can literally say fu to
everyone and do my own thing but
i am starting to put higher value on
personal growth over over money so a lot
of my viewers right now be like funny
you're an idiot what are you doing this
is not the type of stuff you want to see
but it's it's a path i genuinely enjoy
going down and it's what i want to do
you mean the path like like your viewers
are you promoting these women on your
channel yeah so you're are you having
them like play with you or something
maybe play with me slippery slope man
it's very very slow like i said in two
months i should i i might show up here
asking to step on your couch will you
let me
hey look man i'm gonna buy i'm gonna buy
a place soon listen you're welcome to
stay listen i'll charge you a good price
for rent don't worry i'll be cheaper
oh man okay
it's uh oh yeah keep going keep going
good okay it's cool
oh boy um
ask me something specific
so you you broke up with this girl now
you're not appearing in this
of content
are you
i'm
not
no no i'm not in it i'm just making
youtube videos so so basically you make
a youtube video with a girl oh and see
and then promote them on your channel to
their
yeah it's kind of just like tick tock in
a sense
you know what man i would i would have
created a second channel honestly i
would have kept exactly what you have
going is good it would be good to delay
sure it's like it it might be repetitive
to you but it still works maybe switch
things up a little bit but but the like
double down a work like i know you go
nuts double down on work but do that on
a second channel with
i respect that approach it's honestly
probably the smarter approach
but but
this is fun this
jack you're like god dude and it's cool
yeah i am a fetus i need to make
mistakes okay i need to learn i don't
need to make mistakes here's the thing
here's the thing how do you learn graham
no it's not you read a book
i don't think it's like there there are
things out there that you don't need to
make you tell me to jump off a cliff
right now
i'm gonna jump off and be like oh i
broke my legs i i'm happy i did that
won't do it again yeah yeah learn i just
think there are things out there that
yeah you got to experience it's a
blessing in disguise that i can
literally only learn from experience and
it's going to shoot me the foot many
times but i think
as time goes on i'm going to be able to
grow
at a pretty fast rate where i'll be
happy with where i am eventually it's
kind of like rice gum too
like doesn't rice gum do the same thing
uh yeah i don't know too much about him
but i know he's all into that kind of he
does a lot of he like he brings women
onto his channel and they usually have
some sort what i've heard yeah i think
i'm taking more of like a business
approach to things because i really do
like um
you know what but but here's the problem
at least and i'll be honest it seems
like a marketing approach but basically
like you have a hamburger for sale
you're like well let's just put a
hamburger like this
and then that's it or like oh we have
this this uh brand new coffee let's just
do a coffee like this you know it's uh
i think there's maybe more substance you
know like what you mean substance
substance like more depth more like to
this business you want to go here graham
wants to go deeper that's why
like i said graham i am going to be so
open i am so outside my comfort zone
right yeah my content is right playing
video games having a good time talking
about the game not my personal life
giving autobiography so you you take a
cut from these women uh
like is this per sign up or is this just
in total revenue that they generate on
there so the reason why i've said i've
learned so much we are getting so
personal this is good guys this is the
juice i think i think uh some a reason
why i can get so personal with these
guys is because
i don't know what it is but when you
watch a youtuber and you see them in
person you feel like you're instantly
friends you know
it's it's it's pretty cool how it works
yeah so opening up here yeah i agree
when we met
instantly friends exactly yeah
but in front of a camera this is
different story this is outside the
comfort zone this is new terrace just
forget they're not even there
they're not even you're not even
watching this
dropping right now the last thing i'm
looking for
is a relationship i think we would make
videos together i think we'd make a lot
of money and
might randomly get drunk and have sex if
we want to you know i mean like who
knows what it could turn into
and now we ended up
liking each other and then
there's so much and you're right back
where you started and now you got to end
it again because you want your freedom
you know what just happened why i did
that about two weeks ago
three weeks ago see i could call this
stuff
you've been around the block listen i'm
learning all right fist bumps you guys
learning yeah i don't know
but i felt myself getting back into that
rut because it was too soon it was too
soon and i never experienced the things
that i want to experience
as shallow and stupid as they are
honestly but i i feel like they're
yeah the the problem though i mean it's
it's not bad it's like it's stroking an
ego thing of just being like i could do
this like i missed out on this look at
me now
it's similar to okay but it's along the
lines of like i have this opportunity
that many people don't yeah i should
probably take it and see if i like it
you know what i mean so there was this
girl and you were planning on bringing
her onto the channel promoting her only
fence maybe working together doing some
business you guys ended up liking each
other started a relationship two weeks
ago you guys not relationship but we
definitely yeah there's something
like that it's getting
it's going a little bit more than
business the tide is and you're like
wait a second we're going to offshore
and then and then you guys broke things
off two weeks ago
because you had that hunger again
uh not the hunger i think i just uh
after my uh other relationship ended
because things were great but i wanted
to experience things i noticed myself
coming back into that rut old habits die
hard old habits so i was like listen
i've been down this path learning from
experience
uh let's not go down that road again
and uh
i guess we both agreed on that and
now oh boy just keep asking questions i
feel like it's good you got to keep your
life dynamic that's what it is right
like you got to keep things spicy keep
things moving alone i'm worried i i'm
just i'm i'm thinking if there's a way
to sustain that you're going to be very
worried about that a lot of the things
we're going to be talking about but the
juice it's coming did you the juice is
coming you're going to be like very
worried graham i'm going to just pause
you and give you a little heart attack
all right
i spent seven grand on bottle service
no
three weeks ago i don't like this
direction man puke on the ground jack it
worries me i don't like this direction
trash bag for graham about what he's
about to hear
this isn't i don't i don't like
graham again sorry jack
i think there's there's a way to satisfy
all of these urges and
without
who's gonna buy the bottle service if he
doesn't somebody else
somebody else he's 25 25 25 he's 25 he's
making a lot of money he worked
extremely hard he's not doing anything
extremely irresponsible
i need to experience life dude sure it's
like seven thousand
is is golden egg
he's got i don't know if you have you
have four investment properties could
they cash flow like
about to be six if worse comes to worse
youtube says boom you're gone every
sponsor boom you're gone i i could live
off of maybe like i would have about
maybe six seven grand a passive income a
month maybe but i'm staying but i'm
saying there's a way to still satisfy
everything without how great you're
telling me i'm allowing all yours right
now
i i might not listen to your advice but
i'll take it i don't think i don't think
you would listen to my advice i probably
won't you're not gonna say this
like i feel like it's it's pointless
what i would have done you keep the
golden egg going you got it you got a
channel that when i when i saw that was
i know i took it so good but it was fair
it was g-rated pg-rated there's ways to
expand on that bringing other people
within the job but keep it in that same
lane and then you could do whatever you
want on the side but you keep up that
ground let's be honest i'll be honest
right now
the lane was getting kind of boring
though what the lane was getting kind of
boring he wasn't enjoying life man i
think
that's but that's what i'm saying you
could still keep your lane but enjoy
life everywhere else but it's a pretty
boring lane and that's honestly what i
did for six years straight i mean i
enjoyed it a lot and it just got to a
point where
recording turned into work and not what
i enjoy
and now if i make a video with this only
fans girl it's the most fun
s word ever it is amazing and it's still
a business it's not like still a
business it's not like he's
his golden egg just to start up like a
brown egg you know like like he's not
like giving this up to get like my worry
is that uh
you have
i don't know what your competitive
advantage is in this if if you're
bringing someone on your channel uh-huh
why are you different than the hundred
of other people doing the exact same
thing i think uh it's pretty unique
because
solo making content it's fun i can talk
about the game whoa it's great going on
right
i think i do a good job of highlighting
the other people i bring on content-wise
so let's say you're a very attractive
female in a bikini right now right
nice you want to go change right now we
can make it a little more realistic
you could just put it like a cgi
something
all right but uh while we're playing you
suck at the game i can be like listen
graham
you suck at this game and then i can
hear out your response it'll probably be
pretty freaking funny
i think the content um
that i make is honestly i i really enjoy
it now it got to a point where i stopped
watching my normal videos but like these
videos i'm like yo editor they're funny
when's that done i'm like i want to
watch it myself you know yeah and i
think that's
part of a content creator where like
you can't just go down the same lane
over and over how do you know it's like
sponsors yeah
how do sponsors like that oh it's it's
yeah they're they're not the biggest
fans
here's the thing so you're saying it's
lucrative it's this and that but there
is an opportunity cost so oh they're
doing that you're giving up
everything over here that that you're
going to do you're going to puke
all right
how about this instead of us asking you
i want you to tell me the juice let's
finally get the juice out there the
worst case scenario could involve me
losing
above 50 grand a month very easily i
don't listen
your worst case scenario as long as you
don't get addicted to like to drugs i
think it's very minimal i agree honestly
i mean
i i know already you're not going to
lose all your money you're a smart guy
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're not going to
use your mind i following worth the
worst case i'll tell you the worst case
is you you waste a whole bunch of money
and your business suffers all your
entire business suffers that's probably
the worst case scenario it's nothing you
can't ever recover from but it's like is
it worth the risk you know what's the
reward what's the risk is it worth that
is that balance out
uh but that's the worst case
i don't really see but again like
obviously i i you i would never assume
that you would ever go like down that
path of like crazy hard stuff the whole
drugs
um
oh boy but then again it is vegas
you never know anymore if i start going
off that deep end you guys can be like
hey let's let's let's get some dinner
down get sushi but no tell us tell us
the juice i want to hear the juice um
yeah i think it just comes down to um
like i said i've learned more in the
last four months
what have i learned in the past three
years later
[Music]
i think i think a lot of it
well i learned bottle service wasn't
worth it
[Laughter]
so you know what okay so i'll be honest
i got a lot of those experiences out of
the way did you really i was everything
oh it's free okay yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah so jason
gosh like sometimes you don't realize
like how good you have it in the moment
until you know i i it wasn't my favorite
thing to do but like almost every week
he would go and get bottle service uh at
i think it was like hyde or their this
place in la that was good
spots in la but he would always get in
because he just knew everybody so many
people so here's the thing so i i don't
think i've ever seen him like and maybe
he did and i just wasn't aware of it but
most of the time it's like we'll just
call his buddy and he'll be like hey uh
it's the nine of us can we get in at 10
30. sure we'll get you a table and then
it's walking right in yeah literally
walking right into the front there's a
table there everything is is there
and uh so i mean but i never enjoyed it
like i i just i hated i hated loud music
i hated crowds and i'm just i i don't
dance i i don't like yeah i really don't
you do i don't want to like it do you
like it i'm trying to i'm on a week five
bender right now wait are you actually
on a week five bender or was it i i've i
feel like i live in the airport right
now yeah wow see i wonder if this is a
question
yeah
what does a week five bender mean
let's go out all night i've been getting
completely wasted the last five weekends
that's dangerous man every weekend just
not during the week yeah i i i don't
think oh
monday through thursday i've
before my schedule oh my gosh you guys
it's probably similar to some crazy
schedule you guys have but it was seven
days a week twelve hours that you guys
already know that but i've consent i've
condensed it down to
extremely efficient work days monday
through thursday
and i've dedicated this friday saturday
sunday to um
letting loose
how much have you spent on alcohol
tickets and stuff like that in the past
month uh month it's it's probably like a
couple thousand but
it's like buying alcohol for people
coming over it's just i'm finally
spending money on experiences when
that's something that was unheard of me
watching graham four years ago i know
building up allstate the problem is most
people are doing this in college on a
budget
they're doing the same thing with 20
bucks you know every weekend yeah but
you're just doing a bigger scale the
perks of this are i think you can learn
what you want to do faster
what are you learning what's
what do you learn from a from a
five-week bender that i'm missing what
is this
you know those experiences you had where
you're like oh it's 11 pm i don't really
want to go out anymore it's like my 11
pm is gonna hit and it's like i'm gonna
figure out if i want to go out more you
know what i mean so i think
i'm just so new to all of this that i'm
just soaking it in it's hard to say that
i've like learned a lot already but i'm
very uh
dude you learn by trying new things
exactly you learn what you want you
learn what you don't want and i notice i
actually work a lot better if i take a
weekend and go see my family and chill
out for a little bit like then i'm so
excited to come back and get working and
all of that stuff that's how most people
work if i continue and i grind every
single day for like months it just it
kills me you know like i hated it for me
it's the opposite it's so weird if i
take a day off i think a lot of people
aren't
off it throws me off it gets me excited
to come back to work and i i was exactly
like you that's why i think i resonated
with your videos so hard exactly like
you for the first six years because i
didn't really see
the outside world i guess is the right
way to put it sounds like i'm some
philological some i don't know but i
feel like i wasn't experienced i wasn't
exposed to much the point where
i didn't really have like a purpose i
guess so and i loved what i do so i just
threw everything i had into it and loved
grinding like i don't think i was i
didn't want to take days off either
i was very like graham in this scenario
but
recently it was after um
the girl that i was starting to get
really serious with where i was like
whoa going down the same path she hit me
with the question of like okay well if
you're not ready now when will you be
ready i don't know
don't know yeah and i was like
i thought to myself i'm like at the rate
that i have been going at where i've
just been grinding and putting
everything into work i was like
i don't know when i would be ready
that's fair and i was like oh my god i'm
gonna be 45 years old and miserable
why would you be miserable because you
know life experiences no life
experiences
threw everything into work sure didn't
know what i wanted yeah didn't take any
personal time to figure out what i
wanted
and so yeah
i'm just a believer that you could still
figure out all that stuff without kind
of throwing it all
under the grenade you know that's that's
that's what i think i agree i'm risking
the golden egg yeah i can agree with
that yeah and i can agree what i'm doing
is is risky yeah
it is a trade-off i think it's smart
because at the end of it all like what
is life really about you know like work
[Laughter]
um it was
i think uh logan paul who said it he was
he moved to puerto rico he was like
everyone here is a dick but i don't
actually think they're a dick i just
don't think they're trying to impress
people yeah i think you're very
confident in yourself to the point where
let's say let's say my hand's right here
and you don't like that my hand's here
yeah you'll be like hey
get your f in hand out of the way you
won't say that
yeah you're like hey you mind moving
your hand and i'll be like sure that's
fine but a lot of people aren't
confident enough to say what they want
graham is very very very much himself
very very likely
so much himself yeah would you agree
with that sentiment
yeah you've told me to be less of myself
because apparently sometimes i'm a
little standoffish i think it's good
yeah to me it's just i like i just like
don't fake it
no he doesn't but but i like but he's
thinking a lot you know he does think a
lot but there are times where like we've
had guests come over for the podcast
this has happened
more than once no he's not he's not a d
word to them but like he definitely is
not sensitive and he's not like catering
you know what i mean like if you have
someone that's flying in it's like
you're like yo let me pick you up right
now let me take care of this podcast i
was like sitting on my phone a little in
the corner he's like hey sit down we're
starting i was like a lot of people
aren't assertive like that i know but it
does scare off a lot of people because
some people don't understand that he has
no like bad intent with that like he
means no nothing but good but for people
that don't know graham and they're
flying all the way over here from across
the country you know i like to come on a
podcast ram says hey sit down right now
like i stand for the podcast i've been
pulled over more than one time by by
someone saying i don't think graham
likes me and they're sad i would not be
surprised if a lot of people told him
that exactly and i i literally went to
graham and i said dude you have to be
nicer like you have to be like
engaging no no no no no no i'm just
saying at least for the beginning
because if our guest is uncomfortable
the conversation's not going to be good
and i like having good conversation and
meeting these people
and now go on
my side of the story i've been working
on i i get no time to myself like not
even like 20 minutes so sometimes when
the guests come in there's like 20
minutes where we're all kind of getting
ready
i just need some time just to zone out
for a little bit i don't have any time
to zone out and it's usually me in front
of my phone looking at the fish tank
that's usually what it is or just zoning
out just sitting down relaxing that's
all i need but that's not the best
problem and
by you not taking a break earlier from
work and not paying attention to the
guests that's kind of on you all right
alex
especially if they come graham greets
them one real like one quick second and
they they made so much trouble just to
come here yeah and graham's just like
working on his equipment
which is great it needs to be worked on
it's just
learning something i'm learning that's
fine uh i know you've been asking me
what i've been learning through this
five-week bender
i think uh i'm a very
selfish person
but i feel like that stems from
valuing my time
and if i don't see my time being valued
it's like i just don't want to be a part
of it and i'm not gonna
like the whole puerto rico example
everyone in puerto rico probably so well
off that they can act exactly how they
want i think you're in a similar boat to
where
you're not faking being nice and you're
not purposely trying to be an a hole you
know what i mean so
i think uh
a lot of confident people in themself
like yeah yeah they're nice people but
they're not gonna fake uh fake anything
you know what i mean sure and i think uh
i'm trying to figure out if i'm like
genuinely a selfish
douchebag or something but or i just
genuinely value my time and i don't want
to spend time with people that i don't
want to spend time with you know it's so
it's a hard balance all right so that's
that's what you're learning through this
is that's part of it there's a lot i
think it's prioritizing yourself how's
that that's that's a good way to put it
yeah not being selfish just
taking some you time oh boy okay so uh
really like this girl maybe this is a
good time to bring in the bucket list
because i feel like do you have a bucket
like one prepared i didn't really uh
spend too much time on it but the last
like three or four days i was like you
know what effort i'm gonna make a bucket
list i feel like
that was one of the reasons why the
whole i haven't experienced things
that's why the past relationship kind of
uh that was part of the reason why it
ended so bucket list you wanna just jump
into that let's do it yeah
are you in this girl exclusive no
[Music]
this this is where it gets really
confusing
don't tell me we're not okay but
work wise we didn't make it i'm telling
you a lot right now this isn't work wise
we didn't
make it so
if it's like a one-night stand that's
totally fine
but if it's like anything like that
we're gonna be since we're working
together so much that's trouble you
should not be
i i am mixing so much pleasure with work
right now you are going to have a heart
attack i know that's bad
here's the thing you got and you got to
be really careful with that too i'm just
i'm just saying just
in general because i was so
mad i was so aware is that you and her
as your wallpaper listen oh man
listen
i know you and her as your wallpaper
this is going way too far man there's so
many things are basically
exclusively shut up you got to be
careful if you're mixing out with work
because you're such a guy i think i know
that but you've got if you get but you
got this here's the thing you got a mill
like a multi-million dollar business you
know
and you're in
you're putting all of that on the line
i'm just saying all right bucket list
graham i know it's a dumb idea you don't
gotta say it twice all right so first of
all i'll say it three times okay
first one i have two bucket lists two
categories one is before i get into
before i get another serious girlfriend
right because we saw it going down that
path and we're like whoa pull it back
i feel like there's still things in the
experience and then there's no another
bucket list things before life if you've
made it to this point the video i'm so
down i've actually struggled putting
things on this bucket list because i
don't know what else i should put on
here so in the comments we're gonna
bucket list give me like give me one
give me five give me ten i am open to
i'm open to
possible bucket list ideas that i feel
like i wanna experience that i like you
know so i will be reading them furiously
on things i should add to this list okay
so i haven't spent too much time on this
i'm sure i'll add more things but um
which would you guys like first the
before serious girlfriend or before
serious girlfriend before life rip
that's what i have down here before
serious girlfriend
you just love the girlfriend
no i know are you emotional right now
are you into a girl at all right now or
no oh
wow you know jack doesn't tell me
anything anymore he clams up listen jack
i am opening up so hard right here i
know the co-host of this podcast doesn't
join the guest
on this level no but there there there
are some serious uh consequences
what oh because of
no it's just it's just an issue because
i i've spoke about some stuff before in
the past and then
and i just got are you rich
are you whipped would you say or no
absolutely not all right before a
serious girlfriend okay uh one night
stand i've never had a one-night stand
before i feel like it's something that i
should experience i mean a lot of people
see it that way a lot of people don't a
lot of people are like if she's the one
she's the one a lot of people are like
go be a whole face you know i mean yeah
don't have a [ __ ] phase you know yeah
sure um next one spend quality time with
a bunch of uh people whether it's a dude
or a girl and learn a lot about their
life
and be open to new ways of thinking so
that's great i i like that one yeah whoa
we got it
and we're doing that right now so there
you go check
um
go out to enough bars slash clubs to
feel like i'm at the point where i can
walk away from them forever and feel not
the need that i have to do it again
because i feel like if you're like oh i
kind of like that club face but now i'm
locked up with a girl uh it kind of yeah
again so being okay to walk away from
that
feels kind of cool you know i think
that's a good feeling can you give me a
thumbs up on that one too uh yeah i mean
i i mean that was the most half i'm
going to elaborate on it we're here to
learn i'm sure some people got to have
an open mind man he doesn't want to pass
away having any regrets you know yeah
i don't think it needs to be all or
nothing i don't think you need to walk
away from that i think you could still
be in a relationship but go out to bars
and clubs and enjoy that i don't think
yeah i guess i guess more in the terms
of like i'm looking to get laid tonight
yeah and like uh not like a oh let me
experience this with my significant
other okay can you agree with that now
sure all right yeah
it's good that we elaborate
we're very different we get a lot of uh
we got opposites on the
different viewpoints
on graham that's fine it's fine uh last
one actually is um
post the uh like a dan bilzerian
lifestyle on instagram to see if i like
it i think a lot of people don't have
that opportunity
to i think it's a new experience that a
lot of people don't have the chance to
experience but maybe it's something i
like i know it's like a really shallow
like yeah d-bag kind of thing but who
knows maybe i really like it and i want
to experience it more you know
is do you like that or do you like would
it be the validation of that
um i think that's all something i just
want to like figure out okay i think
like i said graham i'm a fetus right now
we're we're learning a lot right
but here's the thing like if if
if this were like and i
i don't mean for this to sound like
disrespectful no no like i totally
understand what i'm saying makes me look
great
if you if if you were 17 and you came in
and said all of this yeah i would not
like even question at all seriously
would you jack i would just be like
yeah that's like that's like every other
way it's like everything like 17 years
i'm 17. that's what you have to think
about i know i the golden egg my 12 14
hours a day was
given to work so hard i know i know but
i guess my problem is that you're you're
17 but i'm raising millions yes yes but
here's the thing graham it's like look i
i don't necessarily agree with like
that's not something i would want for
myself what you just said like all five
or which one
a few of them my worry is that i've seen
so many not so many people but i've
probably seen it one to two dozen people
go down the same path the exact same
thing
and um
i've never really seen it end up like
it was
i guess everyone learns something right
so it's like it's never like
something life altering forever but i've
never seen like a really good outcome
really no no
um
the only ones i've seen i've seen just
in and not in youtube but like a few um
just people that have come across and
like with real estate who somehow could
balance
like that sort of lifestyle with just a
crazy hard work ethic
and
it blows my mind how they're able to be
up until like 4 00 a.m multiple nights
in a row
be at the office or just like you know
work at eight and just
be so product like be the best at what
they do yeah i'm not talking about like
you know agents necessarily but like
also just clients but the one thing i've
noticed with them is that they were
always like that like they they somehow
maintained that while they're building
it but it wasn't like you're building a
business and they went you know crazy i
think they were it was always like the
part where you can respect was or is the
fact that uh
i watched um a lot of people hate this
guy dan blizzarian yeah he went on joe
rogan's podcast a lot of people hate him
a lot of people
uh don't care for him whatever but he
obviously lives the lifestyle he lives
and uh something he said was if you want
a certain lifestyle just create a
business around it
and that's totally true and i think
that's where
this whole only fan's business came into
play because my work turned into
playing video games and getting naked
and i was like that was that was pretty
fun
you know so i'm essentially creating a
business around
something that i want to try right and
it's extremely fun very lucrative
it reminds you know what it reminds me
of um
notch
i don't know what that is notch from
minecraft oh which one's not i played a
lot of money he's a creator creator of
minecraft oh cool cool he sold minecraft
what was like a billion dollars yeah and
he was in his thirties
and here was a guy who created a
business sold it off i think towards the
tail end sold off too early uh no not
necessarily but um
he he just he decided it was time to
sell i think he had lost a passion in
that it wasn't quite the same it had
evolved i think a little bit too much
beyond him he didn't feel like he was a
part of the game anymore
sold it a billion dollars and here he
was at like 35 years old a billion
dollars in cash in the bank yeah all the
free time in the world and nothing to uh
nothing to work on and he hosted these
massive parties in truesdale in beverly
hills
massive and i remember for a few years
i've never been to one of this part i've
that was one of the few things i would
love to have been invited but like i
didn't even know anybody uh who was
going to notch his parties but you would
hear these stories of just like going to
notches and it was like every day and
weekends would be like thursday through
monday thursday through sunday like
every night just party at natchez house
um and then the guy had like a breakdown
unfortunately on twitter where he just
like just went off the deep end i don't
know where what what his status is now
so the more stories you're thinking i'm
gonna go off the deep end i don't want
you to i don't think you would i really
don't think you would but um i feel like
a lot of stuff i'm saying is very stupid
and i i realize that you're extremely
self-aware
really yeah extremely self-aware i doubt
that notch would have that that same
idea
knowing the the the possible like
implications of of his actions by
throwing these massive ragers all of the
time
i don't know
i don't know you know what i guess my
thing is i've seen
i've seen it too many times to see that
like you know if you're betting in vegas
what are the odds this this works out
great in your favor
not as good as what like you would
usually like and listen and the only
reason i care is because you've built up
such like a strong community and
business yeah
um now that i'm missing it scares you
yeah it does it makes me really anxious
because it's like you could spend six
years building it up and then like a
week
just kind of like it's kind of crazy
that's how you bring it down yeah and i
don't think you would like hopefully
like never say anything bad or like
something comes out and then like
you know i guess that could happen even
when you are working diligently but um
yeah i think i think my thing is the
fact that i'm learning so much about
like what makes me happy outside of work
sure is where i can justify the risk
levels that i'm taking
what are the other what are the other uh
goals
the rest of the bucket list so you guys
we're good on the whole before serious
girlfriend one yeah all right these are
more uh tame go skydiving boom buy a
tesla model x a roadster if i like it
um
eventually not work anymore if i don't
want to and live off a passive income at
the lifestyle that i want
um so you can respect that one sure i
haven't fist bumped you all day here we
go
um travel to 20 plus countries if i do
like traveling then go to 50 plus
um
try the best food places in the world uh
travel somewhere completely alone
join the mile high club in a private jet
uh see the northern lights go diving
with sharks float the dead sea get a
shredded six-pack
uh skinny dip in a waterfall slash pond
area
i'll do a couple of those with you did
you just ask me to get naked in a
waterfall dude fist pump no i said i'll
do a couple of those with you yeah
[Laughter]
no i mean i would be down to exploring
some of those things as long as he
doesn't have to pay for the private jet
so all right i asked my question to you
that was gonna make macy kill me
was do you feel like you're ready to get
married
i'm getting there uh what's stopping you
well i mean both my parents were
divorced my sister went through divorce
as well so i'm just more cautious about
it and uh
i believe that like if we have the rest
of our lives to spend with each other
then it shouldn't necessarily be a rush
and i really want it to be something
where like it just it happens
it just it just i wanted to happen
organically i really wanted to feel like
now is the right time it's just
it falls into place it feels like the
like
i guess
so i've i've always done things where
it's just like
it's just everything is always lined up
in the way that it should be and there
are so many things for whatever happens
is meant to happen kind of thing yeah
and um
like uh just like just a few like silly
examples but like youtube like i've
wanted to do youtube since i was 20
years old and i put it off for
six years seven years like after really
wanting to do it and it just
i wish i could have gone back sooner and
like done it sooner but like i'm
thankful i didn't because it started at
the right time it was supposed to uh
same with the aquarium i've been telling
myself since i was like 21 i was i'm
gonna get an aquarium
and um i've kept putting it off and i'm
glad i did because now i really got the
one that i wanted same with the piano
i've i've wanted a grand piano never had
the space for it
a lot of things that you've always
wanted yeah
random questions yes right well let me
finish um
and uh so i know marriage too it's it's
just it's gonna happen when it's the
right time and uh so i've just always
gone with my intuition it's just if it
feels right in that moment and it
happens organically i'm all for it i
like that yeah i like that uh are you a
believer in you get into a relationship
once you get into a relationship you
change together or do you think it could
like drift apart and things just don't
work or you have gosh i mean it depends
on the people yeah um
i i think certainly certain
relationships we've we've drifted apart
and uh with macy's so far we've we've
kept pretty similar she's been really
accommodating
the the most difficult part i would say
especially in the beginning was my work
schedule was like
oh that was a hard one grinding
relentless that's a hard so to take that
into consideration with another person
that i can't just be working you know 15
hours a day
and then that last little hour is like
all right here we go
so
i think you definitely can grow with
somebody but i also think that uh you
know other people just it just happens
this is a random question for you graham
but what's the definition of net worth
is it like
let's say you own assets minus
liabilities
but if you have a mortgage let's say
your minus a million dollar house minus
that yeah so a million dollar house
seven hundred thousand dollar mortgage
300 grand of equity okay cool all right
that's like assets
yeah that was a random question how
about what's your net worth
uh a little over a million
and we could get that higher man we
could get that high listen
no no high fives until three
he's a millionaire
how are three 25
graham you were a millionaire by what
26.
what would you look at that
what happened there buddy
still thinks you're not doing well
enough oh my gosh
i didn't i didn't listen i didn't have a
business as big as yours
be happy for
but like you see the potential and
you're like
you you wanna it is good but your advice
won't help
look i agree i think advice is only
really helpful though when you don't
tell the person to completely change
what they want to do it's like you have
to accommodate them it's like he's
steering himself kind of in the
direction that maybe we can all agree on
is
the greatest look i know you don't want
to endorse it but if you say dude you
have to pull a complete 180. it's like
no he like at least
but it's not going to help him in the
long run you can't you got to say like i
only learn from experiences
you can't really say the poll the 180
you know it's like it's okay to continue
doing what you're doing but maybe you
could say look maybe just separate the
business you could still go get bottle
service you could still do that but
maybe separate your gold
or you could say or you could say
continue doing what you're doing but
maybe stuff here like moderation man no
advice isn't helpful when you tell them
to change they're not to date the people
he's working with i think that's great
to not do a lot of stuff this entire
possible stuff it is reasonable style
but you said to yourself it's reasonable
it is of course it's reasonable it's a
good it's good it's great advice but
it's not going to be helpful to me
exactly exactly but so if he's not going
to listen to you then what is the point
in giving
the 180 advice
if he's not going to listen if it's
honest advice i will take it into
consideration i probably won't agree
with it i probably won't do it right
i respect his opinion so i'll definitely
take it into account
that's all i could ask for and i respect
he's giving me his honest opinion and be
like listen
you're a stupid 25 year old have fun you
know i respect that yeah the other
alternative is like i'm like yeah you go
for it yeah you figure out what you want
this is awesome i'm gonna be i'm gonna
be honest you know but
i told it from the very beginning i
mentioned you know it doesn't matter
what i say you're gonna do your thing
but i think it's pretty clear the the
work dating thing yeah i would as at the
soonest possible juncture
sever that and just keep it separate
this just
snip that yeah snip it it's just
honestly it hasn't fallen on my face yet
and i feel like yeah yeah i know it's
probably it probably will but i'm
learning so much in this process that
it's pretty amazing
yeah you said that quite a few times
what it means guys i'm gonna come back
in a year or two from now and you're
going to be a genius man big brain
massive brandon you're going to be in
massachusetts
i'm learning so much
i came up a 53-week vendor
[Music]
you guys are funny oh my god all right
um what do you what do you think graham
could be doing better yeah i feel like
we always bring our guests on
and graham always basically just
destroys our guests for an hour and a
half and somehow they have a good time
and
coming back and they keep going back but
this time i would love for you to
criticize both graham and i and say
maybe what we could be doing back first
i feel like jack first and do it way
harder
and they're just one friend
what a polite one i feel like this is
gonna be an answer that it's probably
gonna be a boring answer i i would
would want you guys to take a second to
really think about this to see if you
can give something that's not just a
cookie cutter response
um
for you what's something
that you feel like you're going to be
doing recently i feel like you and i are
in a similar situation that you know is
going to be completely stupid where
graham's going to give you the same
response of hey you're an idiot like you
shouldn't do that but it's like hey it's
something i want to try something that i
want to do that's not productive it's
dumb but i just it could be productive
it could be the most risky business ever
you know i mean it's just something that
like you know is probably stupid that
most people would be like hey you know
what you probably shouldn't something
risky that i want to do this is tough
speaking stupid it could be anything i'm
just going to say this because i figure
that this person won't care so it
revolves actually around a really really
good friend of mine okay and when i do
buy a house i actually want to rent a
room to them but this friend that i have
is like
very hyper
very just like
like ocd like in their own in their own
i don't know in their own head all the
time uh and
we like bicker a lot like we've gotten
in fights but but we also have like a
relationship that's so crazy like when
we get together we are so productive
like like first we're the reason why is
because we're both very competitive and
we want to always be better than the
other person whether it be in exercising
whether that be in working and
and i feel like moving him in with me
could either be
so beneficial to even my business that i
like that i have going on like so it's
like a risky thing a risky thing but
also just because like him and i have
kind of like a unique history
basically uh in our relationship and it
could be very bad but it could also be
extremely good so talking about alex no
i'm not talking about i'm talking about
a different person
dang jack as weird as that answer is
that's probably one of my biggest
worries but also one thing i'm looking
so much forward to yeah that's cool yeah
grams definitely what do you got for me
do you
i feel like you're gonna give such a
boring response he's gonna say he's
buying some fish this weekend for this
dad and that's something no monetary
gain you've probably been asked this
honestly but do you have do you have any
regrets or
yes i guess that's the main part of the
question i i i know you're gonna say no
just take a second
do you feel like
maybe you should have went out to one
more of those parties no no no i don't
go one of those parties or it could be
you know what i probably wasted too much
time when i was younger like just being
self-conscious or like caring what
people thought or uh or just being too
nervous
um
there's certainly times where i did not
go out let's say like uh like i was
invited somewhere like this this would
happen a lot like a client would invite
me out and say like hey uh come over or
i'm having some people over the house
friday at 10 but i didn't know anybody
and it was just me and i i
didn't go to a lot of those because i
was like
that would be awkward if i show up and
like i don't know anybody and i'm just
standing there it would be easier just
go to the gym instead
so i look back at that i'm like it
wouldn't have mattered i should have
just done it
stuff like that um
could have probably been a lot more uh
outgoing with stuff like that yeah i
like that no
that's my honest answer
so what do you think we could be doing
better graham i think you're first um i
think you should
i haven't watched much of the graham
stef family channel
but i think
um opening up more
maybe uh
could help you in ways that you might
not realize okay i like that yeah yeah
um jack
i think uh
very nice guy you probably haven't been
taken advantage of a lot in your life
maybe you could be too nice to the wrong
people and it could bite you in the ass
there deep
cool so how do you think this is going
to end
with me or you guys with you yeah yeah
like you're doing all this crazy stuff
what do you think's gonna what do you
think's gonna end up happening it's an
interesting question to turn the tides
on me um
with the whole mixing business and
pleasure thing um
i think i'm just i'm just learning and
taking it day by day and like i said i
feel like i've learned more in the past
four months to
not just focus on work i'm happy i did
focus on work to create a nice golden
egg to where i can build up a nice like
portfolio of hey end of the day even if
things go really badly i'll still pretty
much be okay
and now i can take more risks and not
just trade time for money to
um
do things that i want to do i can
actually just do things i want to do
without having to essentially
drain a bunch of hours into it but i
guess you guys are probably wondering
about the whole
current situation i know recently we've
uh
the girl that i started liking a lot
i didn't go down the same path of um
getting together when i wasn't ready
right so now that i think
as shallow and stupid as these stupid
bucket list things are i think i want to
get them out of the way because i feel
like i owe it to myself to experience
all aspects because they're kind of hard
to experience with
said person i want to be with for the
rest of my life so i think i'll
experience the bucket list thing and
then just continue to learn and go with
the flow as time goes on okay well thank
you so much that was a great answer for
screaming going crazy just do me one
favor oh gosh graham i'm going bankrupt
and living on your couch that's the only
favor i got don't screw it up
nice meeting you oh my gosh
thanks for watching wow i'm out of here
that was definitely by far the most open
i've ever been i did not think that
would happen anytime soon but hopefully
you guys don't want to completely
obliterate me for being that open and
honest but uh
if you respect it and learn from
something great if you hate me
i'm sorry jack it was it was that was
great another film that was awesome
thank you later guys
do whatever intro you want my name is
bunny fufu welcome to the iced coffee
just you got to say that again
my name is bunny fufu